That's a weird a man.
So where do men fit into all of this?
Can we just go to the beach and
wait for women to fix it? No. No.
Up at the end.
And that word is patriarchy
lightening and actually do an
air guitar. Yeah. They catch you.
Your hands get it. Okay.
Yep. Now it's just a lute.
It's not as fun.
Is that weird?
Not something people do.
Look a tad to your left.
That's your good side.
This is my good side. That's
your good side. Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
Oh No.
No.
Men shouldn't expect a reward
for deciding not to participate.
Any horrible system,
depression and do
horrible system of doom
kitten in feminism and it,
the text says, don't do it.
I don't think that'll work. Doom, doom,
doom, doom, doom, doom, doom, doom,
exaggerated. I can just do this whole
time. How's that? That's beautiful.
Know Great. Is that says, feels good.
Yeah. I like this. Yeah, that's perfect.
I am secretly a muppet inside of a
human spot. This is what's happening.
Okay.
How has goes that was from
Greg Kinnear on Taco soup,
which I used to watch all the time.
Okay.
But remember to be compassionate and
patient with yourself and keep working at
it. That was good. Yeah.
You might've, you might've
gotten that. Yeah. Yeah. Do
you want to do it once more?
No. Okay. Let's move on.
I think you got it.
You had a mouthful of dirt.
Do you want to get another
mouth folder? No. No, I don't.
This guy is awesome.
He just responded to every single
one of my tweets with laugh out loud.
If I just, I've just rant. I
shouldn't try to read anything.
That's what's the web point does.
That's what,
that's what we'll get so many more views.
Clearly. That actually probably will.
That's the sad part.
Oh,
start the video over again and
Washington a loop until you get it.
I don't think that tactic would work.
Okay. Okay. All right. Now, nevermind.
We'll start with this.